[Music]
foreign
like ran on me they had a warrant for
the house that that I had all the stats
drugs at uh they caught me coming out of
the house they took my car and then they
stuck me in this uh like Dodge Caravan
and I was there with one officer sat
with him and I'm like yo can you just
let me like give you some money you
could stash the rest of the money blah
blah blah because he had access to like
the money that they caught and I was
like yo just take like five grand and
just leave the rest you know what I mean
and he was like yo you really trying to
Broad me right now and I'm like no no no
but you know what I mean please yeah I
tried but it didn't work